Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and ah,
just whisper and wild check it out.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's like fucking seven 15 in the morning.
My wife's downstairs still sleeping.
Um,
you know what's Hilarious fucking verse.
He texts me,
right?
It like six,
10 in the morning.
He goes,
I was just at a great diner,
ordered eggs over medium.
They came eggs over easy and then writes unreal.
So then I wrote back,
I text back,
right?
I was laying in bed,
my fucking phone goes off.
Right?
So I wake up and that's what,
that's what I read,
right?
So I just text him back and I go,
they didn't care Paul.
Right?
And then he writes t techs back.
How were you up at this hour animal?
And then I text back,
I go out,
cause some guy on the east coast keeps texting me.
How come when you put your fucking phone on vibrate?
I guess it's the vibrating sound.
You think it's going to be silent?
I got to find this thing.
Go into your settings.
Oh fuck you.
You know,
my goal for 2016 is just not going to my settings.
What are they going to come up with?
The fucking robot that does that four year right?
Just goes into your set.
Why you don't want that?
Then you lose total control.
That's like sign it over.
Power of attorney,
at least fucking dope said.
I know the guys and I'd have a a money manager and you know I haven't paid a
bill a year.
So they just have some guy writing checks on their account,
signing their fucking name.
Oh there you go.
Is it good move financially.
What?
Cause you don't want to lick a stamp a couple of times a week,
you're going to just hand over all your finances.
Everything you ever fucking work for to some fucking jerk off
can't do that shit.
You cannot do that.
Anytime you're in a position of a money manager,
you can not do it because there's no way.
You're not making more money than that fucking guy.
If he was,
he'd have his own money manager,
right?
So all he's going to do is see you making more money than him.
And then he's handled it and all the money,
and then eventually he's going to be like,
hey,
you know your,
I think I'm entitled to more.
Maybe I'm going to go to Mcdonald's today on his dime.
And he writes a check Bot up,
up,
up.
Ooh.
For four bucks,
right?
Big fucking chows down.
Yeah.
Any weights if just go pays attention.
See if he fucking notices
about a $4 checked at Mcdonald's was written this month.
Dothan Shay,
wait another month.
Plates.
Safe place safe.
I mean,
we're fucking with jail time.
He had played safe,
right?
You go to three months,
he doesn't fucking notice.
I gave my kids got a birthday coming up.
La.
Let's see if I dip in here and I go to fucking toys are rest.
Let's see if he noticed this and see if he notices.
I go down there and get the fucking Millennium Falcon and all these star wars
shit for my son and for my daughter.
I'll get her the fucking kitty.
Carry all fucking easy bake.
Whatever the fuck you get abroad.
Right?
A little broad LP,
right?
Not Linden.
By talking a little bright here,
right?
So you fucking go down.
You do that,
right?
There's fucking whatever,
150 bucks.
So the camp does,
he notice doesn't fucking notice,
right.
Does Not fucking notice.
And then you know,
he just Spec it.
It just keeps opening and opening and then the gate can't stop,
can't fucking stock himself.
He's taken so much fucking money.
He starts donating some of it to charity.
He's fucking taking his friends out.
I don't worry.
It's on me.
Right?
That's all the guilt he knows it's coming is he sits between his 2000 thread
count fucking sheets at night.
He's just laying there known at some point that door's going to be kicked in.
You know,
he's just going to hear out the door
and then he's going to be like,
did I just dream that?
Boom,
it's going to come open and there is going to be
like Jerry Lunda Guard and fucking,
uh,
and Fargo trying to go out that bathroom window and they're just going to grab
him as he,
Eh,
face down on the fucking bed.
Right.
And then is what's going to happen.
All right.
They'd get them and they go to jail and then what the fuck you going to do then?
You've got to take this to court.
He's already blown all the fucking cash.
Yeah.
Or you know what you could do?
You could make out a check to the fucking gas company every fucking month.
He could do that.
You know,
you could sit down in front of the TV watching a little bit of the,
knew she could do that and just not open yourself up to that shit.
I mean,
that's what you could do.
Oh,
I'm on my fucking stump today.
I just yell at my wife is going to give me shit.
But you know when you're in a relationship,
does this ups and downs in the relationships and there's times when you give a
shit what that person thinks about you.
And then there's times when you don't.
Okay,
seven in the morning on a Thursday.
What?
I'm a little grumpy.
I don't give a fuck.
She'll be mad through breakfast.
I just do to stand.
Why you have to yell that early in the morning?
I don't understand.
I know you don't understand.
I know all day long.
You don't understand.
See a fucking God damn emo.
That's the lady's emo.
I don't understand why you don't just do everything that I want at the moment
that I want you to do it.
I don't understand that I live with somebody else,
then it's a different schedule than I do.
I don't understand.
Um,
anyways,
Jesus Christ.
I,
uh,
you know,
I've watched the last three Celtic games in a row believer in and not,
I can't remember the last time I watched three Celtic games,
regular season games in a row.
Not even when we bought the NBA title in 2007,
2008,
whatever the fuck it was right that season.
I never watched three games in a row.
I just didn't,
I hadn't watched him and for fucking ever,
I was totally turned off by the NBA.
I was convinced that it was fixed.
I said it for years.
I said,
this game,
the fucking league is fixed.
And then they ended up finding a rough that was fixing games that fuck the
Sacramento Kings out of a playoff series.
The Western Conference finals,
if I remember correctly,
and the Lakers went on to the finals and won a championship.
That guy,
he's admitted that he fixed that series.
The Lakers still have that banner.
Right.
And I didn't give a shit.
I would sit now,
I felt vindicated going,
hey look,
this is what I've been saying.
I told you it was fixed and you know what these hoop had said to me.
That's right.
I call them who?
Peds.
You don't what they said they got on.
It's just one guy.
It's just one fucking guy.
Hilarious.
Fucking hilarious.
You know what I mean?
I'd love to see a guy do that on like the view or the talk one of those shows,
you know,
with all the ladies sitting there,
when they bring up domestic violence going over,
fuck,
hey blah blah blah.
Women are beaten every year and just be like,
well you know,
it's just like,
you know,
it's like 6% of guys,
other 94% of us are crushing it
as far as not hitting women.
I'd love to see it do that.
You know what?
You'd be called a fucking sexist,
that God damn animal.
It would probably,
if they could affect your bottom line,
cause it's never ed about educating people when they make ignorant statements,
it's about destroying their ability to earn a living,
which is great.
You know what I mean?
Cause I'm sure that helps that person's hateful heart.
You know,
to have the group that they have an issue with,
take away his paycheck every fuck at wake or her paycheck,
then I'm sure they go,
oh now I get it.
Now I get,
I should be less racist.
And like they,
they do that when someone gets busted for being a racist.
Right.
They get busted for fucking being a racist.
And rather than trying to educate them,
they just kick them out on the fucking street.
Where does,
I'm not saying you don't hold somebody accountable.
I'm not saying you don't sit down until you should try to fucking educate them.
I guess there's gotta be some sort of a fine though,
right?
Get a couple of weeks suspension.
I don't know.
How do you get your really change in a racist?
You know what I mean?
Well,
you know what white guys can't jump,
but they make those little things that,
you know,
they stick on the bottom of your sneakers to give you the quick twitch.
At least they showed that on the back of the,
you know,
the comic books.
Maybe they could make that full like racist people,
you know,
a better yet.
You know,
not better yet,
but have
alleged we switch it up.
How about,
how about nags?
You know,
if you're with somebody who's just a whiner or they nag at that,
just a fucking pain in the ass.
It's just something you can put on the bottom.
This shoe,
give him a little spring in this step,
you know,
get the endorphins moving.
You know what I mean?
Get him to walk around the block.
Maybe see a couple of butterflies,
you know,
chill the fuck out.
Maybe you could do that.
I have no idea.
Do you see those two surfers in Australia and vented that thing that can vacuum
up the ocean?
It really can't,
but it could get rid of a lot of litter.
I don't know how many you'd need to fuck it in the swirl we got going up there
and the fucking Pacific Ocean.
But it was a really cool idea and it was um,
evidently safe Marie for marine life and all of that type of shit.
And it actually gave me hope for our ability to,
uh,
continue being here for any sort of foreseeable future.
And then I was just like,
you know,
what's going to happen?
Is there a,
the game that they're going to have to play to get that thing to a national
fucking level,
international level that everybody would actually use it,
the sea of corporate and political red tape that you would have to go through
and the amount of ownership that you're going to have to give up.
Probably 100%.
MMM.
To actually make that fucking thing happened
is prop.
The chances of them actually using that fucking thing is probably Zeros.
Fucking percent.
That's what's going to fucking happen.
You know what I mean?
Hey,
is a thing that could possibly solve the problem.
What is the thing?
You know,
it's funny as you vacuum up the fucking litter out of the ocean and then where
do you put it?
You know,
then you put it in the ground.
And what about the worms?
Then the parts can't eat it than the cats have nothing to eat.
The dogs have nothing to chase.
You know,
certain groups of people have nothing to eat right then we have nobody to fight,
eh,
then fuck it.
Uh,
our military goes down the j out so fucking,
it's a tough,
it's a slippery slope.
You start vacuum out the ocean.
You know,
I was thinking the other day,
you know,
when the world population got out of control is when Shit couldn't be made out
of natural shit anymore.
Yeah.
You know,
like if you look at kids toys and back in like the forties and fifties if you go
on Ebay and look at those creepy fucking toys played by now,
dead kids,
kids that are now grown up,
gutting divorce you.
Oh Jesus,
I the fucking clouds hanging over me today.
This is what happens if somebody texts me before I want to fucking wake up
grumpy
back then.
If you look at those creepy as fucking toys that looks slightly haunted,
you know what I mean?
They made out of wood,
metal,
the cars,
even like the tires who made out of rubber,
that was all,
all natural shit.
So at the end of the day,
if you fucking threw those things out,
even if you throw them into the fucking ocean,
they don't belong in there.
The end of the day,
what do you got?
You got a little bit of metal,
a little bit of wood,
right?
It's going to break down.
It's going to be fine.
I'm not saying it's trove fucking,
you know,
old dead kid's toys into the ocean.
That's not what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But I'm saying or whatever.
You take it down to the dump and all of that Shit's going to biodegrade.
Right.
It was,
you know,
once we went into the plastics,
just fuck it over.
Cause it was so many God damn wine and kids,
they had more wine and kids so they had fucking trees and rubber that comes to
my tree.
Right.
Jess?
What makes that little lowland?
He can climb that rubber tree plant.
Ah,
fucking it's a tree and a plant.
Okay.
It doesn't make any sense.
And it's the Bruce Jenner of fucking trees.
It's a hybrid.
It's got a leg on either side of the fence.
Um,
let me look to shut up.
Oh,
you get to listen to bill type here.
Just what makes that little ant Danky can climb that rubber tree.
Plant.
Rubber tree plant.
Maybe they just put plants in there so it would rhyme with everyone knows that
it can't climb a rubber tree plant.
Okay.
All right.
Images.
Well that looks like a fucking plant to me.
Rubber tree plant.
Okay.
Why?
What is it?
Any of them say rubber tree plant on it.
Rubber tree plant.
You know what?
My apologies to Frank Sinatra,
whoever wrote that fucking song,
rubber tree plant be the first to view this product.
You can get one for 50 bucks.
Don't.
I'm telling you,
if you fucking had a bunch of those things,
if you had a bunch of rubber tree plants,
right,
and you just grew them in a greenhouse outside your house,
all your neighbors would think that you were fucking,
you know,
dealing weed and all you would do it was just making yourself your own homemade
radio tie.
Yes.
Can you still buy studded tires?
Do you remember those fucking things?
They had nails in them.
You know,
you could run over children with them and they blame the kids studded tires.
Now you go studied tires for a stud list,
snow tires,
images for studded tires.
Look at that or you get a little traction.
Then of course some rednecks got to do it with the spikes coming out.
Yeah.
I love those rednecks who like raw Roland call that fucking dope.
Like to make it some sort of statement and they always turn it on and they blow
the black smoke into a Prius.
Yeah.
So he's a guy's like pumping their fists.
MMM.
I Dunno.
It's one of my favorite things.
So what was I talking about?
Yeah,
you got to go back to make the kids' toys.
If I was elected president,
if I was running for office,
right.
I,
that's what I would say.
I would go up there.
I would completely ignore Donald Trump.
And whenever he talked to me,
I would just look at the crowd and be like,
is he puckering his lips or his lips still?
Puckering I can't look at him.
He looks,
he looks like an old angry fish who,
uh,
didn't achieve his dreams.
And now we pick it on all the younger fish.
Sorry.
And is,
here's the color of a goldfish.
Um,
I would just say listen,
but we need to do is we need to get the population down to where we can make
children's toys out of wood,
metal and rubber again.
Do you understand me?
We got to stop vaccinating people for polio.
We got to let the measles come back.
We got up,
we got a burn off the herd.
Okay.
So we need to do so we can once again make toys,
but a wood,
metal and rubber.
Same thing with cars.
And I don't give a fuck about safety.
No more crumple zones.
All right.
Go back to the old days in a sticky and fucking model.
T's,
you know,
driving around in a Goddamn toaster.
That's what's going to happen.
And then you whip around the corner,
you have flipped the fucking thing over and that's it for you.
Right?
And you biodegrade and sodas the car,
cause it's going to be no more growth hormones and preservatives or any of that
shit in the fucking food.
Oh yeah.
People are going to starve.
Goddamn right.
They are tech on a fucking starve.
Okay.
But they're going to biodegrade.
Yeah.
And they will create,
will throw them all on the same fucking ditch and they will create a fossil fuel
that we can use to gather in the future
kind of octane.
You think that would be set the right word.
Okay.
You know,
human beings turns into a fossil fuel.
Do you think we'd be an 87
91 or [inaudible] 93 whatever the fuck that means?
Is that just a purification process?
You know,
it's funny.
There's actually somebody who's not in that industry that actually could explain
it.
That's the kind of person you do not want to be in a car with for any low,
like
I can't want it.
What the fuck?
I'm trying to say.
Long specific time.
It didn't sound right in my fucking head and I still said it.
Long period of time.
Yeah.
That fucking guy who just knows a little bit about everything,
but he's still fucking in that fucking one bedroom apartment.
You know that guy still in that same apartment.
He's been there for 13 fucking years and there's not a subject on the planet
that you could fucking bring up yet that content has not got his bag of gold.
Why is that?
I'll tell you why.
If you had a ton of fucking person that no one wants to drive across town within
a fucking car,
do you think somebody wants to spend eight hours a day in a board room with you?
They don't.
They're going to bury you in that sea of cubicles,
right?
They're going to use you as a litmus test to see who the fuck is tough enough to
get to the next level.
Okay?
I'll tell you think that Susie Q down there has got to stuff for maybe a corner
office.
I know what we'll do.
We'll stick them right next to Burke.
Who fucking knows something about everything right,
but can't even clean the sleep out of his fucking,
I have him sticking his head over a cubicle every day with this stale,
not quite bad,
but not quite fresh breath.
Listening to her conversations on the phone.
You know,
Daddy,
what are you doing this weekend?
Let's get brunch.
I'm dying to go to low.
Liz Vc of the best French toast that he pops his fucking head over the wall.
Actually,
it's French toast was not created in France.
Little known fact.
I mean,
she could fucking handle that.
She gets the corner office day after fucking day.
It's literally,
it's gotten to the point she can't have an orgasm because she just keeps hearing
his fucking voice in her head,
you know?
Okay,
boyfriend thinks she's fucking around on them or I'll fucking,
life has fallen apart pitch.
She says new age woman,
right?
She's willed herself not to have a period she's going for that fucking corner
office.
You know something.
If you're sitting there right now,
go,
what the fuck is this guy talking about?
I'm not talking about anything.
I have a,
a moral obligation to talk for a half an hour every fucking Thursday.
God,
I'm only 20 minutes in.
I was woken up before I wanted to wake up and uh,
you know,
I'm a little grumpy
by the way.
My new fucking Bible,
uh,
my new fucking religion is Mario Batali's cookbook.
I made the chicken.
How does a hundred style,
which I had never heard of.
It was absolutely fucking delicious and I messed it up a little bit to when it
was still fucking delicious.
Could use a little more salt.
And I had my heat on a little bit high,
but I took the chicken off early and I didn't overcook it that God,
uh,
cause the lovely Nia came in.
She goes,
I think it's done.
Go.
You think it's done?
She gets,
yeah,
she goes cut into it.
I go,
I hate cutting into it.
I don't want to cut into it cause if it's not done then I'm letting all the
fucking juices sounded dries out.
She goes,
I think it's done.
I said,
all right.
I could have browned it a little more,
get a little more of a golden color.
But other than that,
it was fucking delicious.
What's in it you want to add?
You want,
you might have not have asked you.
You know what?
Let me hit pause.
I'll read it for you.
Hang on.
All right,
I'm back.
Okay.
Yeah.
Chicken hunters style.
Okay.
All right.
He says,
chicken cacciatore seemed to be a subset for every mediocre chicken dish ever
served to me at a restaurant,
at a rate in restaurants in the seventies and eighties.
I love these talking shit right out of the right out of the gate saying
everybody else who's fucked up this dish.
But I'm not,
um,
anything with a mushroom or an onion in it.
Qualified for the title in my world.
Chicken cacciatore is simple braise.
That depends on a lot of quality,
a lot on the quality of the bird itself,
but Blahblahblahblahblah so,
um,
Cleo,
you gotta stop staring at me.
It's going to happen.
We're going to go to the place you want to go to.
All right.
You already did number one.
You already did number two.
And I gave you a big can of food with that extra shit you liked on top.
All right,
I have a podcast to do.
I have an obligation.
Don't yawn in the middle of this.
Where would you be without me?
And where would you be without humans?
You know what you'd be,
you'd still be a wolf right now.
Right now you'd be eyeballing me.
Is that thing week?
Can I go for its throat cliff?
Okay.
And a different set of circumstances.
You'd fucking eat me.
Do you realize that?
Huh?
I'd never met a dog.
All right.
I never had a dog that just fuck it.
You're not a fucking little chihuahua.
What are you doing?
How you I get claiming me?
Is that what the dog whisperer says?
You don't get down off the couch.
Don't lean into me.
I'm gonna Relax.
Got,
dammit.
I fucking love that dog.
Anyways.
Um,
yeah,
so I made it this week came out fucking great.
Uh,
the name of Mario Batali's book,
which I highly fucking recommend is a Molto Italiano 327 simple Italian recipes
to cook at home.
And uh,
let me tell you something right now.
Don't let the word simple for you.
All right?
He keeps fucking,
I got to learn how to do this.
What is this fucking thing he keeps saying?
What's that thing where you put the fucking meat and water like overnight begins
with a B?
I forget what the fuck it is.
He keeps bringing that shit up.
It's driving me nuts because I can't figure out what the,
hang on a second.
Hang on a second.
I'll find it here.
Cleo.
Stop looking at me like that.
I love how you,
cause you can't,
you just think you're just gonna Stare at me.
MMM hmm.
Where is it?
Oh,
for fuck's sakes.
Whatever.
You guys know what I'm talking about.
You fucking,
it's in an old school way of like Louise to try to preserve the meat.
But then people found out that I actually added flavor to it and it keeps
sending me to like page three 76 to learn how to fucking do this shit.
Brining
brining was originally used as a means of preserving meats and other foods.
Since the advent of refrigeration,
such preserving techniques have become unnecessary,
but brining has become popular again as a means of increasing the succulents of
meat or bird cuts,
that lack of fat or great flavor.
So I got to learn how to fucking do that.
Isn't that great?
Cleo?
Like I didn't have enough on my plate.
Speaking of which,
you know,
what an exciting thing I'm going to good go do today.
I'm going to get my luggage repaired.
I got this fucking pigeon toed wheel that's been fucking the bane of my
existence as I go through every fucking airport in this country.
Um,
I can only carry the luggage on the right side if I'm on the left side.
And that thing is that that fucked up wheel is leading the charge.
Um,
it's over and it's going to affect my mood and I'm going to be rude to people
and,
uh,
I'm finally going to get it fixed before I start another year,
um,
out on the road.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
the Patrice O'neil event is coming up.
Uh,
the benefit is coming up in,
uh,
Jesus Christ and a couple of weeks.
Are you kidding me?
That you can mine?
MMM,
it's going to be on January the 26th.
Now I'm getting into town before then.
Wouldn't it be nice if all freckles maybe did a couple of warm updates in the
tristate area?
Uh,
look for an announcement on those shows in the next week or so?
Um,
and I'll be working with an old friend of mine,
uh,
Al Del Benny who I started off with a long time ago and he's coming in all the
way from Australia.
Um,
we all started out together with the late great Patrice O'Neil and last year
when I was working Sydney,
Australia,
I reconnected with them and we were telling all these hilarious stories about
Patrice and how much we missed him.
And he said,
man,
I would love to come back.
I go,
you'd fly all the way in from Sydney,
Australia.
And he goes in a fucking heartbeat.
That all right.
That's what Patrice meant to all of us.
So he came all the way back and,
um,
we're going to be doing some shows together to help him pay for his trip.
And then we're going to do the benefit on Tuesday night.
Should be a great time.
Um,
which is the,
one of the good things that's actually come out of this tragedy,
this fucking awfulness is,
uh,
you know,
we all get to get together once a year,
um,
and do a good thing.
So before it gets sad,
I'm going to move on.
Um,
where do we go here?
Yeah,
so I've watched like three fucking Celtic games in a row and I'm already
watching the Bruins games.
It's like I was,
I feel like I'm still living in Boston right now.
It's kind of Nice.
You know the games come on at like four,
four 30 out here.
I taped them.
I start watching them at like six.
I can get the game done in about 90 minutes.
I can still go out and do my spots.
It's great.
So I actually know some of the Celtics names now.
We've got a guy,
Isaiah Thomas,
no relation point guard,
Jae Crowder.
I like
what the fuck's the other guys?
They uh,
whenever I look at his name,
I can't,
I can't fucking pronounce it Kelly.
Okay.
Oh,
Nina.
Whatever the fuck it.
I can never fucking room about a Goddamn name.
I Dunno.
I have a dent.
We uh,
Tommy Heinsohn takes each one of the best big men passing in the game.
Kelly Olynyk Day you,
yeah.
Had to like walk away from it.
So we lost a Brooklyn.
We Be Brooklyn.
And then last night we fucking had the game,
the whole fucking game and playing the Pistons and then they just kept chipping
away at it.
I mean,
I don't know shit about the Celtics other than they score like 30th 37 in the
first quarter every night.
And then you know,
you're like,
I literally texted version like the Celtics and we'll lighten it up,
you know,
shooting some high percentage of the next quarter.
They just shit the bed there.
We say that about basketball to game a rugs.
It's a game of runs.
Oh yeah.
It'd be sure it isn't fixed.
They're not shaving points to keep the fucking crowd interested because if you
blow them out in the first quarter that people are just going to turn the
channel.
I Dunno.
So whatever.
Then this fucking kid,
right?
Reggie Jackson,
no relation.
So how old are you?
He's fucking kids are coming around.
They get the same names of the greats that I watched when I was a kid.
Uh,
Reggie Jackson,
Jesus Christ,
kids got ice water in his veins.
Lacy did that game.
I don't know anything about them,
but you know what's killing me is the Pistons.
They're back.
They got mixed filthy and McNasty again,
except it's the white version.
Okay.
Yeah.
This fucking bearded white dude going out there.
Right.
This guy,
he used up five fouls in about six minutes and they kept him in for the whole
fucking game.
He never filed out.
They had him and then they got this other big white dude who looks like the
fucking,
one of the bad guys.
All areas.
Burson.
Yeah.
Ellie Salva Dude,
you get,
if you tell me that guy doesn't look like that guy from the James Bond movie,
metal mouth.
They had them,
they had the metal in his mouth.
Furry,
a very clever name.
Um,
you had him at a,
who's the other guy?
Aaron Bates.
White,
mixed,
filthy and white.
Mcnasty.
Now for people who didn't watch the Celtics pissed as rivalry and don't know
that reference.
That was a bill and beer who I guess was a white guy.
I guess now it's all white McNulty,
filthy McNasty,
um,
Bill and beer and,
uh,
the other guy,
what actually liked
Rick Mahorn does that right?
Macro Hawaiians.
That's right.
And uh,
what's this?
They were fucking,
you know,
Mohan was just a tough motherfucker.
Bill Laimbeer was a piece of shit.
That guy was a piece of shit.
But I gotta give it up to that guy at the top of the key.
He fucking hit that shot every God damn time.
But other than that,
he was just a piece of shit.
And I remember watching the 30 for 30 on the bad boys in Detroit and he goes,
you know,
we used to try and play a mind game.
He's trying to play mind games.
He act like he was out there playing chess.
It's just like bill,
you would take in guys knees out,
you would throw in elbows to the head.
That's not a head gate.
That's just punching somebody in the face when they're looking up,
trying to get a rebound.
It's not a head game in that dead deep.
Um,
two favorite things was when Larry Bird punched him in the fucking face
as lamb berries at the biggest whiny look on his face.
It was like a giant Danny Ainge.
And when,
uh,
chief Robert Parish just gave him like,
he gave him,
like he would punch him with like his forearms gave him like this overhead,
like a,
it was like,
uh,
when the UFC guys do like the fucking grounded pound except what was the inside
of his forearm.
And he was standing behind them.
It was so fucking great,
but he was on the ground covering up like a little girl and he was such a piece
of shit.
The refs didn't see it.
They knew what happened,
but they didn't call anything.
It was fucking tremendous.
But whatever.
Anyways,
they got these two guys now,
um,
uh,
Aaron Baynes and Earth Sun
les over whatever the fuck their names are.
Uh,
just,
I dunno,
it was more about the Bains gap.
Judging these guys on one fucking,
I'm sure they're good players,
but I'm judging them on one fucking night.
But,
uh,
what's his,
but I don't know.
I thought I thought that dude,
Reggie Jackson looked fucking great.
Um,
and then on the other nights,
I'm much the fucking Bruins.
It's great.
Even though we fucking can't get a run going lost to the capital's again fucking
concept.
Um,
whatever.
I'm going to keep watching.
Is that a true fan who clean up?
Relax.
I'm almost done here.
How much time I got left?
Oh,
32 minutes.
All right.
So that's,
uh,
that's about it.
I did my contractually obligated fucking blabbering by the way.
It's actually been raining out here in la,
which has been tremendous.
Um,
okay.
God knows we need,
it was like the first sustained,
we like two days of like,
we're rained for like half the day,
like pouring,
which is tremendous.
And they always get,
you know,
La people shit because they freak out when it rains.
It's like,
well,
we live in a desert.
And then secondly,
people just go lie,
don't drive.
It's just,
it's fucking rain.
Well,
what happens is,
is when it doesn't rain for a long time,
what happens is on the roads,
all the fucking
shit from the cars.
Okay.
You know,
oil,
antifreeze,
transmission,
fluid,
brake fluid,
all that shit that leaks.
It just builds up
on the ground.
And then when the water lands,
it becomes like this soup.
So I'm not saying it's like snow,
but it's a little worse than east coast because I used to flip out when I was
out here,
like these fucking people,
they're acting like it's a blizzard out here.
It's just rain.
Just fucking go.
But uh,
it is a little bit,
yeah,
it's a little bit of both.
They drive like pussies out here and uh,
the rain is a little more slippery,
uh,
by Jesus Christ on the worst.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
That's the podcast with this fucking all the Thursday afternoon podcasts.
I just checked in on.
Yeah,
just,
just checking in to see how your week's gone.
I hope it's going good.
I hope you know what?
I hope you have a wonderful dog in your life like I do right now.
That's just sitting staring at me because it has an inability to talk.
So when it does is it walks over and it sits down like a foot away from me when
it is an itching itself and it just stares at me.
Cleo,
you want to go outside?
Get off.
Huh?
Cleo?
See if I get to talk.
Cleo,
do you cleo?
now what are you getting Mike?
Frank,
come on.
Get up.
Get Out.
You got to do it here.
Shit.
Okay.
It just fell on her face.
Glio get off.
Oh,
what are you doing?
You just fucked with my,
my mixed up though,
right?
She won't do it.
Try One last time.
Cleo.
No,
she just sent a luncheon today.
All right.
That's it.
I got it.
I got,
I gotta take this fucking thing out.
I'll talk to you guys later.
Enjoy the,
the um,
the flashback,
the back of the day podcast.
Uh,
she fuck with the volume.
That's it.
Uh,
Kevin,
nice weekend.
Fuck you.
Alright,
there's a couple of advertising things that I forgot to read here,
so let me open it up my email.
Oh,
here we go.
Trunk Club,
everybody.
Holy Shit.
2016 is going to be a game changer.
You're fresh stat.
Stat the off right?
Well,
when the right pants,
the right the right shirt trunk club is here to handle your wardrobe so you can
focus on what matters.
Trunk Club takes the hassle man out of shopping by finding the best clothes for
you and your style.
You'll look like 1 million bucks and we'll always have the perfect close for the
thethen.
Oh my God,
that's so springtime@trunkclub.com slash burr.
You answer simple questions about your style preferences and size and are
assigned an expert stylist.
You styles.
We'll hand pick clothes from the best premium brand brands.
Just approve of what you like and send back what you don't and just like that.
A trunk full of fucking close comes to your doorstep,
filled with a hand close it are perfect for you.
Sorry.
It's getting hot here in the car.
Try them on.
Keep what you like.
Easily return what you don't in their prepaid trunk.
Trunk Club is the subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges,
just great clothes.
It's a brand new year full of possibilities with trunk club.
You'll start off the year looking great in clothes picked just for you.
If you didn't hear that the first 15 times get started today.
And Trunk Club will style you for free plus free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes that you keep.
We got it to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/bird that's from club.com/.
Bird.
All right,
zip recruiter.
Um,
as a business owner,
your company's only as good as the people you hire.
Posting jobs in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates these days.
Short staffing leaves little time to post a dozens of job sites.
Jesus Christ.
What do we do?
Well,
you could post to a thousand plus job sites with one single click.
Click where at zip recruiter be instantly matched all the candidates,
candidates from over 6 million resumes plus watch brand new candidates roll in
every day.
And ZipRecruiter's easy to use interface within 24 hours.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Um,
today you can try zip recruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/borough one more time.
ziprecruiter.com/birth.
All right,
listen,
Nah,
the throwback stories this year,
uh,
all this week for Thursday are going to be classic Rosebowl stories.
You know,
Jay law had the one about him with the Bart Nick being a teddy bear and all that
shit.
Hope you enjoy him and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Have a nice weekend.
You'd kind of
hit the side of the gathering.
And Man,
I was bombed his blood on my hands and have all the signs of it.
All right.
Well I went to another rose bowl,
everybody and I think I'm just now starting to recover.
First of all,
what a fucking game.
I um,
just like the rose bowls are already unbelievable.
But to add that whole play off atmosphere to it was just insane.
And uh,
this year being all the guys we got over there,
we were so fucking organized this year
we,
we had,
we had fucking everything.
We had fucking everything,
food,
booze,
other stuff.
Jason Law had put on a display of tailgate cooking then it,
it was,
he had a career year.
That's what we were saying.
He had a breakout.
It was just fucking,
it was the best breakfast sandwich I ever had.
Then he made these ribs that were unbelievable.
Then we went to the game and at the end of the game it was freezing out by then.
And we were smart as how smart we were.
We brought a quarter wood and one of the grills we turned into just like a
firepit and everybody else too is waiting for the traffic.
Every ball,
these people coming and gathering around our little fire going,
you guys are smart.
It's really smart.
What I left out is we brought everything except fire.
We've flipped,
forgot to bring a lighter.
They were bringing the grills and they were bringing the charcoal.
So I assumed that they were going to bring the fucking lighter.
And I brought the letter every year.
So I guess that one was one was on me.
I don't know what,
but other than that it was a,
uh,
it was another amazing time.
And,
um,
it was fucking hilarious with basically we get into the game,
got in on time because it's a fucking playoff game,
right?
And there was so many people getting tickets said I couldn't get four together.
I got two and two.
So we were like couple rows,
two,
three rows in front of a Bart,
nick and lie ahead.
And we're sitting there,
you know,
and I'm pretty,
I'm not as bad as it was last year,
but I was fucking,
uh,
I was feeling no plane.
All right.
I was definitely more than dehydrated at that point.
And all of a sudden I see security walking out with Jason lie head and there's
no Joe Bortnick in Jay is looking at over at me with his hands,
like up like what the fuck?
And he's yelling at me and I'm going,
Jay Jay where they take it and I'm in like,
I'm in the middle of this fucking road is like 30 people on one side,
30 and the other,
this old school stadium,
right?
Total fucking fire hazard.
Right?
I'm like,
Jack,
where you go Jay and he's fucking yell at me.
I can't hear.
And the whisking him out so fast.
There's nothing I could do other than I just keep going with Jay.
Jay,
try
looking at me like,
what the fuck turns out?
Uh,
I don't know.
Bart.
Nick was outside.
He was in the stadium,
but outside the stands,
I guess he had sat down or something and not at off the,
when he came to,
there was like fucking 20 cops surrounding them because he's such a big guy.
I thought they were like,
they were like,
what is this guy starts swinging,
we're fucked.
And they went down there and they told I,
they looked at his ticket
and they went up to get Jason.
That's what they did.
And they said,
we got to,
he's been overserved,
which is the understatement for all of us for 2015 and a lie ahead.
To his credit,
the only thing he did better than cooking was talk his way out of that.
He just kept going.
I come and look at the guy and he,
he,
he's,
he's a teddy bear.
He said he's not,
he's not hurting anybody.
He's going to go up days and sit down.
He's going to be any of that.
He's a,
he just kept saying he's a teddy bear and Joe was just looking at,
I'm teddy bear,
they fucking let 'em in fucking lawyer.
The politician gets him to his seat,
he sits in his seat and then promptly fucking passes out and some lady behind
law head goes,
hey,
you're going to have to get him outta here.
And Jay just looked at her and said,
hey,
come on.
Wait,
wait till he's not,
her name was,
he's a teddy bear.
Okay,
listen.
And she fucking jogged back at him.
And Jay was just like,
listen,
if tell you what,
if you will just watch the game,
you're not even going to see them.
Okay.
I mean,
I can wake them up if you want me to.
I'll wake him up.
I don't think you're gonna like it,
but I can't wake him up.
And people just started laughing and it was over and we had a wonderful time.
I'm seeing two of the top college football programs play each other.
It's a hell of a game through two and a half quarters.
And then,
uh,
Oregon,
I got to give a shout out to the ducks just for shutting up the Fsu band that I
didn't have to hear that,
that fucking Tomahawk Chop again.
And I,
I dude I fucking called it that ban,
knows three songs,
they know the school song,
they play something else and then everything else.
Yeah,
the whole fucking game.
And um,
it was,
I mean,
I don't know,
I would like to see a little bit of a closer game,
but uh,
I really enjoyed,
uh,
the fact that they shut that band up.
Nothing against Fsu.
I actually really liked the Seminoles and I've always loved that program.
But um,
somewhere along the line that Tom locked chopped just fucking
okay.
It would be like if at the Red Sox,
like,
you know,
awful it is when they sync sweet Caroline.
Just imagine if they did that between every fucking ending.
I mean you'd want to kill yourself,
right?
If you want any sort of a human being.
And that includes being a red sox fan,
cause I want to jump off the fucking monster when I hear that fucking song.
Just once.
I want you to look at around him,
fucking women putting their head on the fucking guys shoulder.
It's just like,
ah,
okay.
I Dunno.
Maybe I dunno.
Maybe I should be a little more positive about the shit like that.
I have no idea.
Um,
okay.
The rose bowl,
everybody.
Oh Dude,
I'll tell you right now,
if you're gonna pick a beer to start the day with,
I'm telling you Miller high life,
ah,
in,
uh,
in the,
you got to get it in the bottle.
Oh my God,
the sun's just coming up.
We've got there seven Oh four in the fucking morning.
It was freezing cold out.
There was a frost on the fairways.
I'm telling you guys,
you've got to fucking do this.
Okay?
You don't got to go to the Rose Bowl.
Fucking pick something that you and all you had dumb guy friends are you and all
your dumb fucking women friends.
Just,
you gotta have that one thing you do every year.
You got to have that.
I don't give a fuck what kind of responsibility you got out.
You got to have that one fucking thing.
So anyways,
we got to,
the frost was on the fucking fairways.
Okay?
I actually said this year when I got out,
I said,
hey guys,
guys,
got to go.
Take this in right here.
This is the best part of the tailgate.
It's the beginning and this time tomorrow you're going to wish that,
that this fuck it moment.
I actually know because you'd be too hung over.
Three days later when you get all the poison out of your system,
you're going to be fucking longing for that feeling.
Do we get out of that truck ear to ear,
fucking grins.
And then Bart,
it's got this thing that he yells out to everybody to the entire parking lot.
Um,
I don't want to say what it is cause he yells,
it's so fucking loud.
And so far,
nobody's ever found our fucking tailgate,
which has been great because we make a spectacle of ourselves.
Uh,
you got to do it.
So anyways,
the Rosebowl let's,
let's read this thing here.
Dear Billy football,
uh,
love the podcast.
She knew it was special,
was nothing short of amazing.
Thank you very much.
And thank you everybody who's been watching it,
rewatching it and telling other people to watch my new special you people are
all the same.
I'm sorry.
Jesus Christ.
I'm sorry you feel that way.
Oh,
Jesus,
Bill.
Um,
I really appreciate it because a,
this one has been getting the best response and uh,
you know,
that makes me look good with the people I'm in business with over there at
Netflix.
So,
uh,
you guys did me a solid.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Um,
anyways.
Anyways,
here we go.
Anyway,
I had a question about your Rosebowl outing last weekend.
The game itself was great from that opening Oregon drive when Mary Yada,
I hope that's how you say his name.
I didn't,
it's two Heisman trophy winners.
I don't even know their fucking names.
I was so busy this year.
I was so hammered.
I even had a fucking program.
I had no idea.
Uh,
Mary Yada pitched it to the guy who somersaulted to the one yard line f and
later completed the two point conversion.
All that was great.
The beginning,
uh,
to famous James flopping around,
fumbling for an Oregon touchdown late in the third.
It was just a great game and I was thoroughly jealous.
You were there.
You're obviously an Oregon ducks fan.
Uh,
my question is,
can you share with us a couple of your favorite moments from this year is
Roosevelt?
I kind of did that but there's probably some more.
I'm sure you had.
You in the goon squad.
You roll around with a gun and some funny situations or conflicts.
Ps,
I saw la ahead and part Nick in Boston for the all things comedy tour.
They were great guys and had the pleasure of sitting with Bart Nick at,
at the bar while Jay crushed it on stage.
Cool dudes.
I would love to drink and smoke stokes with you all some time.
Happy New Year and go fuck yourself.
You Apron wherein cont.
Uh,
that was a good one.
You best?
Um,
I think I've already told the,
uh,
the stories.
Yeah,
it's,
I don't want the football or the food.
I mean,
I dunno,
I was pretty sober,
but I was kind of a consistent level,
like blacked out.
Um,
okay.
I don't know what it was.
Was it this year?
Just the whole fucking thing.
You know,
it was cool as watching a father with his two sons and he was playing automatic
Qb,
it teaching his kid the cornerback to get inside,
you know,
inside the receiver and a watching the big brother,
older brother fucking rivalry reminded me when I was a kid,
I sat there smiling and drinking a beer,
probably look like a pedophile,
but I was actually thinking nothing but clean stuff.
Everybody looks like a pedophile now.
Um,
I dunno,
I gotta be honest with you the whole fucking days,
a goddamned blur.
I remember most of the game I did.
I passed out a little bit in the first quarter for about a minute and a half
football time and,
and then the second quarter for about a minute and a half.
But,
uh,
other than that,
you know,
I crushed waters for the rest of the fucking game.
I didn't have any beers afterwards because I had to drive.
And that's by then,
you know,
we stayed there till like eight 30,
nine o'clock at night.
So by then I haven't drank in like eight hours,
so I'm actually so sober up fucking hung over at that point.
What's the Rose Bowl this year?
And I did not drink.
I did not drink.
And I know there's a lot of you who are disappointed that I didn't drink because
you want me to fill up your life with a hilarious story of me making an ass of
myself once again to kick off a new year.
Well,
God dammit I didn't,
but I stood around and I watched it enough other people,
fuck it,
do it.
And I still have plenty of stories and I got the braids cells to remember them.
Uh,
so fucking awesome game.
It was Wisconsin versus Tcu and uh,
I was like most people,
I'm like,
who the fuck is Tcu?
And then you look in the program.
Let me go grab the Rose Bowl program.
Hang on one second because you guys just
just relaxes.
I'd walk across the road
trying to find the Rosebowl program.
Oh,
here it is.
Look at this.
I found it.
I really need to get an assistant on this podcast.
All right,
I'm back.
So here's the Rosebowl program and basically
the rose bowl this year,
if you were going to turn it into an awful,
you're going to turn it into an awful made for TV movie.
This was like,
I,
I guess it was a story about respect.
All right.
In that,
you know,
people barely respect Wisconsin because they never go to the rose bowl.
I can't remember the last time they won the big 10 championship,
but they finally won it.
They want it and,
uh,
they beat the likes of,
let's,
let's see.
Let's see.
Let's see who they'd beat.
All right,
let's go through their whole fucking season here really quickly.
Stop Rolling your eyes.
You fucking commy non sports fan cunt.
All right.
Start off the year they beat Unl v.
These are the cupcake games early in the ED and they beat San Jose State,
Arizona State.
There's a PAC 10 team,
Austin Peay.
Who is that?
Somebody who's name did they play?
Like one guy?
Uh,
then they beat Michigan state.
Then they beat Minnesota.
They beat Ohio state,
right?
Big 10 Iowa.
Purdue,
you've heard of these teams?
Indiana,
Michigan,
one of those teams.
They actually lost two.
But I went by too quickly.
Northwestern,
you know,
they played some fucking teams teach.
See you on the other hand didn't play shit.
So okay.
She down there outside of Dallas,
Texas,
Christian.
Oh Gee.
She's university.
And you wonder why no one gives a fuck about the mountain west program.
I want you to write me and tell me just exactly.
Okay.
Oregon state though,
that's PAC 10,
that's a Tennessee tech.
This is,
they're undefeated season.
They beat Oregon State,
Tennessee tech,
Baylor,
Smu,
Colorado state,
Wyoming,
Byu,
air force,
UNL,
V,
Utah,
San Diego State,
New Mexico.
That was,
they're undefeated season.
And this sitting there scratching the top of their fucking heads,
wondering why there that people are questioning their record.
All right,
so here's the deal.
I'm sitting there going,
all right,
I like this big 10 even though the big 10 isn't what it used to be considering
they went,
oh,
and five on fucking new years day.
Um,
who doesn't like an underdog?
So I'm going,
well,
fuck it man.
I'm going to root for Tcu even though they have Christian.
Oh Geez.
He's in the middle of their fucking name,
which you know what that means?
They automatically think they're better than everybody else and Jesus loves us
best despite the fact that they're preaching that everybody needs to be more
understanding like Jesus.
Somehow they miss the irony of the fact that they feel like they're the chosen
ones,
like all stupid fucking religions do,
right?
Jewish people think they are the chosen ones.
Christians think they're the chosen ones.
Muslim thinks that you know what?
You guys are all a bunch of Douche bags,
all right?
None of them matter.
That's why there's so many of us.
If we were special that only be like nine of us once there's 7 billion of
anything.
I mean,
we're about why we're not special anymore.
Okay?
Do you understand that?
Well,
like socks,
you know,
actually some poor people can afford socks.
The socks is still important to some people,
you know,
I know what the fuck I'm saying.
So they got a fucking bee in their bonnet about how nobody's respecting them.
So I'm sitting there,
this is before I talked to anybody from Tcu.
I just saw,
all right.
You know,
purple and black.
Those are decent colors,
man.
I liked those.
Wisconsin.
I'm looking at all these fatties from Wisconsin,
you know,
walking around,
just horrible,
horrible shape.
I think when,
you know,
when Europeans look at America and they think of of the fat fucks,
I,
I think,
I dunno,
I think they send away for a Wisconsin broche university brochure every year.
I don't know what,
because Jesus Christ,
those were some healthy fucking people.
All right?
Evidently the recession has not hit Wisconsin yet because those people have
plenty of money for extra food.
So anyway,
so I'm sitting there and uh,
we start to walk into the game,
right?
Me and three of my buddies were all good and I don't name names on this fucking
thing.
We go to walk into this goddamn thing and I start looking around after Oh,
after a wonderful tailgate.
We really did it up this year.
Plenty of booze.
Uh,
which I did not partake in.
I brought a 12 pack of water.
Go ahead,
email me,
call me a fag.
I don't give a fuck.
I feel great.
You fucking cunts.
Look at,
I'm still defensive about it,
you know,
at least done one of those,
those,
I'm not a preachy,
sober person.
I'm not going like,
you know,
why do you do that?
What are you,
what are you running from?
I know why you're doing it because it's fucking fun.
And I'd still be doing it if my head didn't get three times the size of its
usual enormous size.
You know my head when I'm not boozing looks like one of the moons of Jupiter.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't need to continue adding to it,
you know,
and then have it be like Pluto and then scientists can fucking debate on whether
or not it's a fucking planet.
All right.
You fucking fucking fucking,
there you go.
See I needed the help there.
The F word for me is,
is my,
my uh,
uh,
what are those things?
Is the HGH of my fucking comedy.
All right.
And I will continue to use it and I don't give a shit cause they're not banned
in my industry.
Um,
anyways,
so what was I saying?
Oh yes.
We had a great tailgate.
We show up.
I became in the back way this,
this,
this year.
All right.
We parked right along the fence.
We were right near the clubhouse on the golf course.
And then you can,
I could literally see one of the lights that lights up the stadium.
So we were right there.
There was no way we were getting lost this year.
Actually brought a frying pan,
brought some eggs.
We had burgers,
hot dogs,
steak.
We had shit to throw in the omelets.
Cheese,
everything you want.
We had a spatula,
we brought tongs,
we had napkins.
We had a fucking garbage bag.
We had a grill bag of charcoal,
four bags of fucking ice,
a coolie and everything.
We had fucking corn chips.
We had salsa.
We had two bottles of Ho Jarrod fucking pickles,
ketchup.
We had everything we had.
We had,
we had real forks and steak knives for the stakes.
We had everything except for a fucking table.
God,
next year it's going to be the per every year two bottles,
a crown royal,
a case of fucking beer.
We,
we will,
we will ready to go.
We even had orange juice for the fucking eggs.
We will ready to go and we forgot a God damn table cause one of the ways we
start the day off with one of the best fucking omelets.
You ever going to have new year's Day sitting on a golf course on a sunny day,
no one,
the rest of the Goddamn country snowed in screaming at some ticket agent that
they got to get back to Albuquerque before they yak.
You know,
shits the bed,
right?
We forgot a God damn table,
which isn't bad when you eat an Omelet,
but when you're eating the fucking steak,
that's an inch and a half thick that's been cooked at best rare.
Supposed to be medium rare.
Okay.
It was,
it was just medium rare.
What happens is we got it on a paper plate.
And as you use pressure to cut into that,
it creases in the middle and you see this puddle of,
of,
of grease.
It just starts coming.
It comes close to your balls and then it goes away.
Just like the tide coming in and you're sitting there going,
you know,
I really should a just drip the rest of this grease down into the grass,
kill a couple of lady bugs and then continue on with the eating process.
But it tastes so fucking good.
You Go,
you know what?
I think I could do it one more time.
And then you do it.
And what happens if fucking rolls right off onto you get jeans and you haven't
noticed.
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
What you spill,
where you spell it,
you could have your arms outstretched if you spill any sort of liquid.
It not only does it land in your Crotch,
it lands right at the head of your Dick.
So it always looks like he pissed your pants.
So that's what I look like.
I had grease on the front of my pants.
Um,
I,
meanwhile I'm sitting here watching all these Wisconsin fans walking around and
they got these candy striped fucking overalls.
They look like Richard Simmons shorts.
If you fucking mugged him and cleaned out his closet of early eighties fucking
gay,
his running shorts ever.
And you somehow turned them into overalls,
you know,
be wanting of women were wearing them,
that'd be kind of hot.
Right?
But there was a bunch of guys wearing them too.
They,
they all look like they look like it looked like a jugglers convention is the
best way to put it.
So I'm sitting there going,
man,
I like the big 10.
I want to root for Wisconsin.
Then every once in a while,
because it seems to be like 80%,
75%,
maybe 70 at the smallest Wisconsin fans,
and then Tcu,
so you know,
who doesn't like an underdog?
So I start walking towards the stadium,
right at,
uh,
I'm thinking of it to go for Tcu.
Fuck this.
I helped this little,
uh,
mountain west,
whatever.
Fucking,
I don't know what conference it from.
Huh?
Um,
I hope these guys win.
And,
uh,
I start going up to the stadium and,
one of my buddies elbows me and he turned around,
he points to these Tcu fans and this guy is wearing brown loafers,
these light purple,
uh,
like Roy Docker's with the Tcu emblem and then like a v Neck sweater
and like these ray bond fucking risky business sunglasses on.
And He,
I like if you,
if you were casting a movie,
do you guys see Facebook that Facebook is social network?
Do you know how like the Harvard guys were,
this is what this guy looked like.
And I was like,
oh my,
are you serious?
Is this guy and an anomaly or is this really what Tcu was all about?
My buddy literally goes to me,
he goes,
that's it.
I'm rooting for Wisconsin.
You know,
I look at this fucking guy and I,
and I was sitting there going,
you know what?
I think he's right.
Not On,
don't,
maybe it's just this one fucking guy.
And then I see another guy,
he has on a purple fucking blazer with gold buttons.
Oh well shook some pleaded slugs and low first
to the game.
And all of a sudden I started looking at these.
This is not all of them,
but I could,
15% of them are dressed this way,
looking like those rich kids who fucking,
you know,
uh,
air quote,
accidentally killed their date,
you know,
and then they say it was consensual because she wanted rough sex too.
And that daddy has enough fucking money to get him out of it.
That's what they started looking like.
So I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Fuck this.
I'm,
I'm rooting for Wisconsin now we're in the crush to get in the game.
And I look in front of me and there's this pasty fat fuck Wisconsin fan in front
of me with the Wisconsin have turned around.
And I don't know if it was dry skin or Eczema.
He had a perfect band of it going around the back of his,
you know,
his hairline at the back of his head and the flakes of it,
we're on the back of his sweatshirt.
I know.
I hope you're not eating.
Okay.
So I'm looking at him gone.
Oh,
horrified.
Absolutely horrified.
And then I'm turning around,
I'm looking at these fucking slack and a sport coat wearing douchebags.
And at that point I didn't know who I was for.
I was actually hoping that during the flyover,
one of the jets would go into the crowd and they could just start all over
again.
It was,
it was horrific.
Worst Group of fans I've seen.
And in three years,
granted I was sober this time and I could actually remember this.
So I go into the stadium,
right?
And,
uh,
Lo and behold,
I'm in the TCU section,
right?
And I'm like,
okay,
uh,
I don't know if I liked this and I just didn't all signage here.
Start here.
Okay.
This girl like three rows back,
Jay,
come on,
come on.
Frogs.
And I go,
frogs.
They're the fucking,
I didn't know what they were.
We got to give it to Wisconsin.
Badger is a bad ass fucking Ama.
TCU horned frogs.
Okay.
And,
and that their mascot,
look,
I don't need,
it looks like something out of like the,
that star wars bar scene,
you know,
and against go frau come.
I'll TC TC you and I'm looking at the girls and they,
uh,
they,
they have their jeans
tucked into their cowboy boots,
like they're in that band,
great white,
you know,
and then on top they have like these dime store Dolly Parton cowboy hats on.
And I was like,
oh my God,
I fucking hate these people.
And at that point,
and I was sitting right in the middle of them and I immediately just became a
Wisconsin Fan.
Now in defense of Tcu,
I think if I was hanging in the Wisconsin section,
I would route,
I would have rooted for Tcu.
Yeah.
I would have rooted for Tcu,
you know,
in the middle of me just screaming that tasty ag,
you come off frogs.
I can't tell if Nia just laughed or the guy downstairs yelled at me,
I'll,
that's a dark.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
My fault.
Or it's Mel Blanc.
Um,
good.
Anybody imitate a dog barking better than that guy.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So then I just sat there and uh,
just was rooting for Wisconsin and I just want it and I,
and I,
I just,
and another thing too that's really fucking annoying about Tcu you fence okay.
Is
Okay,
no matter what's going on during the game,
they have a reason to fucking put their hands in the air.
See,
can't see the fucking game.
Anytime it was third down they had this gay little thing,
well you know,
you make the a I'm okay sign.
They would do that signifying third down and then they would just sort of shake
their hands like,
Ooh,
just in case you don't know what down it.
And it everybody.
So it's like third down and anybody who watches football knows third down is a
really important fucking down as a fan who played,
have paid a fuck load for the ticket.
You want to see what happened and these fucking idiots is so busy going to the
loo.
You couldn't see anything.
Then,
not to mention there's fat whore in front of me who from the size of her should
have been a Wisconsin fan.
But then again,
I've been to Houston,
Texas.
Okay.
Those people like their barbecue to the,
these are the people that really make America look bad.
It's the fucking middle of the country.
You got damn people.
I don't know what your problem is this because you're landlocked.
Don't they have swimming pools where you people get through a couple of laps
people on the coasts or in shape?
All right.
Seattle all the way down to San Diego.
These motherfuckers are in shape.
Go ahead.
San Diego,
go right up the coast.
Los Angeles,
San Francisco or Portland,
Oregon.
They're in shape.
A Seattle.
Vancouver.
I even leave the country and they're fucking its shape.
You start getting out there in Nebraska.
Our Wisconsin.
Huh?
Fucking people are are horrific other than Florida.
Florida doesn't count.
All right.
Florida is a,
I don't know what it is.
It's like the ball bag,
but he says it looks like a Dick to me.
It looks like a fucking 56 year old.
Scroll them just hang in there.
Um,
after the Dick got lopped off.
anyways,
so they,
they handed out the like,
like them doing that third down thing wasn't enough.
They handed out these fucking little purple like rags.
Okay.
First of all,
stealing from the Pittsburgh Steelers,
the terrible towel.
They steal that.
And then the on them,
it said fear the frog,
which they stole from a Maryland fear the turtle,
right?
The first school to actually admit that they have a bad name,
a bad mascot.
Fucking name.
So then what day with this fucking fat whore in front of me,
I swear to God,
every God damn play.
Okay.
Her fucking team would be,
we had engine seats were,
was in the other end zone at Wisconsin's 10 yard line trying to drive in for a
score.
Okay.
They're,
they're 90 yards away.
If you're standing on the goal line,
forget about being 40,
50 fucking rose up in the Goddamn Stan.
And she would be sitting there as she's talking to a friend too.
That's what killed me.
Classic brought it a game.
She's sitting there shooting the shit.
You know,
she probably went there for the tournament of fucking roses and she just kept
it.
I finally,
I tapped her on her fleshy shoulder
and she immediately took it.
As I was saying,
put it down.
I said,
can you just wave that?
Can you wave it more in your like in front of you?
Which this is the funniest thing ever.
She does,
and immediately realizes that when she does it,
she can't see the fucking game.
Welcome to my world.
You're fat whore.
That's what I've been dealing with for the last three fucking quarters.
So then what she did was she then switched into her left hand.
Okay.
Because not only is she a fat whore,
she's a dumb fat whore.
Okay.
And the first moment when I tapped her,
she was like,
oh,
this guy must be a Wisconsin fan,
you know,
because he's telling me to put it down.
Then she realizes,
oh,
it's in his way.
Did she waves it in front of her face and realizes,
oh,
now I can't see.
And you would think at that point light would dawn on our fucking fat head.
And she'd be like,
oh,
I get it.
If I wave this thing,
people behind me can see the fucking game.
Not this fat whore,
not this one.
She fucking puts it in the left hand and starts waving like that.
Like that's the solution.
Like she notice that there's another fucking 80,000 fans to her fucking left up.
It was the worst.
And it's times like those where I just a times like those were made for taster's
choice.
Remember that coffee just brew up a nice hot pot and he just dumped it right
over her fucking head.
That's what I would have liked to in a perfect world.
And as she screamed
from the scalding Burns,
um,
she would collapse afterwards.
So maybe pass out either way,
she would be out of my way.
And I got to tell you,
that would be the equivalent of three normal Americans who live on the coasts,
who lived near the ocean.
Hey,
you know what?
I just realized that's how I'm gonna make my million dollars,
my multimillion dollar so I can parachute out of this goddamn business.
I've been trying to come up with
some bullshit that I could sell for 1995 late at night.
And I think I just did,
you know,
I'm going to sell,
uh,
ocean water.
Yeah.
And Little Salt Shakers for 1995.
That's what I'm going to do.
And I'm just going to go,
you know,
have you ever noticed how,
people who live on the coast of this country are in shape,
you know,
and now I'm now just show a bunch of good looking people running down the street
with their knees nice and high,
like the Wisconsin fucking marching band,
which was the shit,
um,
just running down the fucking street,
you know,
high step in it.
And then,
uh,
the white version of high stepping,
which is basically ring our knees up to our waist as opposed to the Grambling
black version where you basically,
you know,
you're,
you,
you couldn't do it in a dome stadium because you would break your fucking toes,
whatever black people we're trying,
we're trying anyways.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I would,
I would sell it and I would just say,
and then you get,
if you know,
are you tired of being fat in the middle of the country?
And just so somebody who is sitting a been taken a bite out of it and then just
look at the camera like,
you know,
throwing their arms up like woo,
yeah,
I am sick of being a fat fuck,
you know,
you know they have sent a bunch on the east coast wire on the west coast.
Why aren't they fat fucks?
And I'll just,
I just spin it.
It's because they live there,
the ocean and there's smelling that salt water in the air and I'll just make up
a bunch of shit.
I'll pay off some fucking people in the FDA.
Uh,
it doesn't seem like a hard thing to do considering half the drugs that could
approve nowadays,
and I'll just say it's because of smelling salt water air that you're able to
eat Cinnabon and shut off those fucking pounds.
And I'll sell it like little bottles of fucking Cologne to every fatty and the
fucking Midwest and I'll make my money.
And then I'm going to move to Denmark and I'm going to pay 90% taxes yet have
free health insurance and uh,
you know,
in a little vesper I'm going to go around those little fucking I little streets
out there.
I'm trying to put together a Scandinavian tour,
by the way this year.
I'm really looking forward to that.
Um,
so there you go.
You know something like you,
I also lost interest halfway through that.
So that was the rose bowl for me this year.
I didn't drink.
I had a,
uh,
I had a fucking awesome time.
I remembered the game.
Congratulations to a,
let's go froward.
Congratulations to you.
A horribly horribly dressed human beings just horribly dressed.
Trash,
white trash is the only way to describe what I saw it there.
You guys really looked like you never left the Greater Dallas area.
Um,
you know,
I'm going to go out on a limb here and I would say I'm never going to get an
opportunity to perform at that school.
And if I ever get an offer,
I'm going to be really suspect of it,
thinking that they actually listened to this podcast.
Oh my God,
the dime store.
Fucking
every the woman,
women are dressed like that.
Dolly Parton movie.
Best little whorehouse in Texas,
except they were serious.
They probably put out my best path for this one.
I saw a guy actually took a picture of him or did they zoom into them?
I have some video.
I got to give it to my web guy,
um,
of this guy.
He was dressed in a suit with a big black Stetson looking like fucking,
uh,
Jr Ewing standard.
You know,
if it was the early eighties,
I would,
he would have looked good,
you know,
but it's fucking 2011,
dude,
it's,
it's time to let that go.
You're fucking,
uh,
oil man slash coke dealer.
Look from fucking 1981 30 years later,
you're still rocking that look like dead serious,
dead serious.
These are the kind of people that think like there's that you can cure
homosexuals,
you know,
and uh,
like one of those countries,
singers like a hit,
so they just write a song about how great America is and the two right.
And the fans are too dumb to see the fact that they just trying to make some
money invisible
at a
time
strong enough.